buonasera a tutti mi chiamo luca sini vi
parlerò oggi di sharing economy e
turismo non ho sbagliato l'immagine ho
scelto questa immagine apposta perché
oggi stiamo parlando del cambiamento e
credo che ogni volta che si parla di
cambiamento si debba parlare anche di
un'opportunità
io in questa immagine avete una pallina
da baseball o meglio vedo un'opportunità
che arriva e vorrei prima di iniziare
che passiate un minuto sopra questa foto
a guardare le facce e le reazioni di
queste persone verso questa pallina
questa opportunità che arriva c'è chi la
vuole fortemente
c'è chi è molto preoccupato c'è chi
assolutamente incurante e c'è anche
invece chi la vorrebbe ma non sa da dove
iniziare
allora le auto come detto mi chiamo luca
sini e sono qui oggi anche come co
fondatore di una start up che si occupa
di sharing economia e turismo per
iniziare vorrei condividere con voi tre
cose che in questa vita mi hanno
condizionato parecchio hanno
condizionato il mio percorso fino ad
oggi
la prima è stata lo sport quando ancora
non potevo permettere facevo i giocatori
di pallacanestro sedi professionista non
sono mai riuscite a sfondare ma ho
imparato tante cose la prima che ho
imparato e dallo sport è quello che un
un insieme di persone possono riuscire a
fare quando marciano congiuntamente
verso lo stesso obiettivo
qualcosa che è un singolo non potrà mai
raggiungere finalmente smise di giocare
a basket a 24 anni grazie all'erasmus
erasmus che feci prima in spagna e poi
in irlanda e che mi ha permesso per la
prima volta di approcciare una cultura
diversa dalla mia e di viverla fino in
fondo ed iniziare un percorso che ha
portato a vivere in sette città diverse
negli ultimi sette anni
in uno di questi sette anni sono tornato
a casa e ho avuto
fortuna di lavorare nell'impresa
familiare accanto a mio padre mio padre
titolare di un'azienda che
commercializza prodotti di abbigliamento
multimarca ho visto cosa vuol dire
l'arrivo del cambiamento e
dell'evoluzione in un contesto stabile
tradizionale che fino a ieri era
abituato a basare il proprio business
sui numeri e all'improvviso si trova non
avere più la banchina minima certezza
ho visto quindi quanto sia importante
essere sempre pronti all'avvento del
cambiamento e dell'innovazione e ho
visto anche cosa vuol dire tirare avanti
con tutti se stessi la propria idea è
qualcosa in cui si crede così dopo un
master in inghilterra sono tornato in
italia per presentare la mia idea di
business a 1 stata qui kant non sta
applicando un evento in cui in un minuto
puoi presentare la tua idea e se la
poteva piacere
vieni premiato per portarla avanti nei
tre giorni successivi con questo
sofisticato metodo di voto postit 15
selezionarono e per tre giorni lavorano
al progetto tre giorni molto intensi e
fumo premiati a questo fu l'inizio della
mia avventura che insieme a pietro
d'andrea i miei due co fondatori ci ha
portato a creare ritmi wright è di
wright e un marketplace online dove oggi
potrete scoprire è prenotare delle
esperienze locali autentiche in
compagnia di un esperto locale che noi
chiamiamo local frant molto semplice
come tutti portare di questo tipo si può
andare sul sito sulla psi si può
scegliere si prenota e alla fine questo
ve lo dico perché è importante per il
discorso si condivide la propria
recensione col resto della community
perché siamo arrivati a investire la
nostra vita in questo progetto
andiamo a vedere quello che è successo
nell'industria turistica che rappresenta
solo uno dei modi in cui l'innovazione
ha cambiato il nostro mondo gli ultimi
30 anni venti trenta anni fa eravamo
abituati quando volevano viaggiare ad
andare in agenzia a scegliere tra i
venti pacchetti che ci venivano proposti
all'improvviso è arrivato google sono
arrivate tutte le informazioni che
volevamo a portata di mano online ci
sono abituati andare a cercarle online
le trovavamo e quindi siamo andati
sempre più spesso online fino al momento
in cui queste informazioni sono
diventate troppe non riuscivamo più a
gestirle allora abbiamo cercato
scorciatoie scorciatoie che abbiamo
trovato grazie a community dove le
persone recensiscono e ci permettono di
filtrare le informazioni che troviamo
online questo però a perché ha portato a
quello da cui cercavamo di fuggire
quella standardizzazione che cercavano
di fuggire perché oggi milioni forse
miliardi di persone cercano informazioni
online e vengono indirizzate verso
quelle dieci venti attrazioni che hanno
il miglior feedback on line e questo
porta a una standardizzazione 2.0
dell'esperienza di viaggio
questo è vero nel turismo ma è vero in
tanti altri settori
cosa abbiamo imparato che sullo
smartphone possiamo trovare ormai tutto
qualsiasi tipo di informazione in
qualsiasi momento ma ad oggi non
possiamo ancora vivere esperienze
autentiche col nostro smartphone
qualcosa doveva cambiare questo
nell'utilizzo della tecnologia è da qui
che nasce un movimento come quello della
schering economy
non so chi di voi qua se a familiare con
concetti sharing economy però a me piace
definirla così è un movimento per cui
non esiste più il possesso delle cose ma
piuttosto l'accesso a tutto e allora
tramite la scelga economy un privato può
guadagnare condividendo delle risorse
che ha a disposizione come esempio un
posto libero in macchina una casa vuota
una camera vota a casa sua o del tempo
libero
e può quindi offrire un'esperienza
qualcuno e guadagnare attraverso quella
che è prima di tutto un'esperienza anche
sociale però scende con lui rappresenta
molto di più rappresenta un cambiamento
su tutto e tutto l'ecosistema il mondo
in cui viviamo
il primo player a livello mondiale
quello che è impastato di più è stato
sicuramente a airbnb suoi bimbi potete
mettere in affitto la vostra casa o
meglio una stanza della vostra casa
ma perché sono così devastanti questi
questi marketplace queste realtà perché
non è solo la tecnologia ma è la
community che sviluppa e che si crea
grazie a questa tecnologia il
passaparola una crescita scalare che non
è possibile in altri contesti
per farvi capire se nel 2008 super baby
avveniva una prenotazione al giorno
appena quattro anni più tardi aveva una
prenotazione ogni due secondi
questi sono meccanismi di crescita che
il mondo tradizionale non sarebbe in
grado di leggere né di regolamentare né
di monitorare e allora c'è uno scontro
cioè dobbiamo andare a capire cosa
succede in questo confronto tra il mondo
tradizionale in cui siamo cresciuti a
cui ci hanno educato e il mondo nuovo
semplificato dinamico che in cui stiamo
vivendo
andiamo a vedere ad esempio come
funzionava in italia ma anche in altri
paesi
quando si voleva andare a offrire un
servizio
c'era un ente pubblico che stabiliva
tutti i servizi che potrebbero essere
affetti e metteva una norma a fronte
della norma emetteva una licenza chi
voleva offrire il servizio finalmente
titolare della licenza
poteva andare a vendere il proprio
servizio tramite degli intermediari
offline
oggi questo è cambiato oggi non c'è più
intermediario off line
ma c'è un marketplace online la
tecnologia ci connette mette in contatto
chi vuole offrire un servizio con chi ne
vuole usufruire è soprattutto quello che
è cambiato è chi decide chi può far cosa
chi decide chi è bravo a far qualcosa
non è più un ente pubblico centrale che
mi dice tu puoi farlo ma è una community
milioni di persone che condividono la
propria recensione e ci permettono di
formare la nostra reputazione online in
un sistema che andando a crescere
diventa sempre più meritocratico allora
il mondo in cui stiamo vivendo è un
mondo connesso è un mondo dinamico ed è
un mondo sempre accessibile ed è anche
un mondo particolarmente competitivo
però attenzione non è necessariamente
più competitivo e semplicemente cambiata
la maniera in cui si compete quindi se
fino a ieri
io ero un utente passivo oggi posso
posso scegliere di essere protagonista
attivo nelle mie scelte e acquisti e
domani posso scegliere di essere
imprenditore per un giorno mettendo in
atto la mia stanza suoi bimbi ad esempio
e l'italia qua come si comporta stiamo
mettendo una legge sulla shing economy
che è sicuramente un modo di reagire a
questo cambiamento però attenzione
perché reagendo si rischia di andare a
bloccare un fenomeno che ancora non
conosciamo e che non sappiamo come si
evolverà quindi la domanda che ci
dobbiamo fare veramente
dobbiamo adattare il nostro sistema la
scenic economy al nostro sistema
o piuttosto la il nostro sistema alla
shing economy io credo che la risposta
sia questa
dobbiamo semplificare per essere più
rapidi per reagire ai cambiamenti del
mercato dell'ecosistema in cui viviamo e
completiamo e dobbiamo permettere alla
gente di partecipare a questo
cambiamento
quindi se fino a ieri il pubblico ci
diceva chi poteva fare cosa oggi il
pubblico dovrebbe permettere questi
sistemi di evoluzione di cambiamento
tutelando un po tutti ma solo con dei
paletti distretti che ci permettono di
operare al nuovo e dovrebbe considerare
anche il vecchio rendere al tradizionale
a quelle persone in possesso di una
licenza di competere con questo nuovo
che completamente deregolamentato è solo
in questa maniera si potrebbe creare un
ecosistema in cui tutti congiuntamente e
attivamente contribuiscono alla crescita
di questo nuovo mondo quindi per
chiudere questa pallina da baseball per
me rappresenta la scenica economia
comunque come la si voglia chiamare
questa opportunità che sta venendo
persino è un'opportunità per iniziare di
stile tutto in maniera diversa
è un'opportunità per il pubblico di
avere un ruolo da abilitatore ed è
un'opportunità per tutti noi di iniziare
a far a far crescere questo sistema di
prenderne parte
e grazie a noi di indirizzarlo verso la
direzione giusta che permetta a noi e al
nostro paese di crescere una volta per
tutte grazie
non cassini